al'approche du nouveau scrutin pour
élire le maire de la ville de trappes
othman nasri guy malandain et mustapha
al harbaoui ont donné rendez vous aux
trappistes mardi 28 septembre à l'école
jean jaurès une union républicaine à
trois visages pour un programme commun
je porte un certain nombre d'idées
depuis des années sur le renforcement de
la police municipale pour assurer la
sécurité et la tranquillité des
trappistes sur la défense des locataires
face aux bailleurs quand cela ne
respecte pas les règles sur la baisse de
la taxe foncière pour la rapprocher des
villes voisines sur la nécessité d'avoir
de la mixité y compris dans nos
commerces pour avoir des commerces
diversifiée et des professionnels de
santé qui s'installe rassemblés pour
trappe une liste qui voit sa lle des
hommes politiques de droite et de gauche
les trois candidats ont souhaité mettre
de côté leurs divergences jus pour
changer une vie politique je vais prenez
comme exemple tout à l'heure des
présidentielles on votera pas la même
chose mais la situation a dit elle ce
qui est essentiel c'est la ville de
trappes ses habitants ce sont d'avenir
la dynamique et puis il ya la sérénité
qui doit revenir pour qu'on reprenne
comme on vigier yahia de il ya deux ans
une soixantaine de militants et
habitants s'est rendu sur place ils sont
venus poser des questions ou soutenir
les candidats j'attends une chose c'est
qu'on rassemble la ville qu'on rassemble
tous les habitants les trappistes qu'on
laisse personne au bord du chemin au
bord de la route et des toutes les
populations c'est à dire d'abord les
jeunes
les personnes âgées les personnes en
situation de handicap et les classes
moyennes les classes simples les
personnes lambda comme moi attrape le
nouveau scrutin aura lieu les 10 et 17
octobre prochains